or someone named Samuel Leeds thanks so
much for coming to my channel I'm a
property investor and every single
Wednesday I interview one of my success
students who's become financially free
as a result of my training this week
because people always say to me but
Samuel you always interview people that
have only just become financially free
so I found someone who's been investing
in property for 17 years however he came
to my crash course he came to the very
first time I ever ran the crash course
for free guess what after coming to the
crash course I taught him about HMOs his
first hate Shimer that he got made him
financially free this was back in 2016
2017 I'm gonna be interviewing him today
he's doing very very well also please if
you enjoy my channel smash the like
button subscribe turn the notification
bell on us in SEC Lords Lee Lawrence and
my very first free
[Music]
so you've been probably investing for
longer than I have but you first has to
2003 yeah and you pair it through in
property yeah and you bought you did a
load of property flipping in 2009 yeah
first buy too late 2013 yeah yeah I know
this I know more than you about your own
policies why did you come to the crash
course in 2016
initially because I was buying in the
Birmingham area no you just came to heck
on me right yeah and I thought I'd get
some information on the area
I hadn't it's my first HMO I was
purchasing that time so I wanted to
learn about that and who was sauce that
for you
it was yourself myself the whole team
yeah yeah and so the purchase was going
through at the time so I come on the
crash course I think to learn Tim to
learn some skills that I probably
wouldn't wouldn't know at the time that
networking I did network with work but
networking also it's just engaging with
other other property professionals and
trying to solve as much information as I
could did you enjoy it
I did I did there was it was aspects of
it that we know it was things that I'd
already known as you know into property
but I enjoyed I think what I took from
it was I enjoyed talking to people and
probably being a bit of a mentor as well
yeah so there was people there that
wouldn't have the experience that I had
and I met up with him afterwards and
there was a serious people and I know I
said I stayed in touch and I gave him a
bit of advice and vice-versa
I did learn a lot from it and I asked
you if you wanted to be part of my crew
and you kindly rejected me no you didn't
even reject me you just never ever got
back to me I think we reconnected just
recently because I know you've done
great things in property and you've been
in promise you longer than I have but
your HMO that I source for you is your
very first taste HMO yeah
and I always like to get case studies
from back in the back in the day and I
know you've done lots of other crazy
things within property management you're
now doing random stuff which we can talk
about but I really wanted to get you in
to talk about that HMO and what's
happened with it as a case study because
that
was back in 2016 yeah four years ago
yeah so another time Lee I was telling
everybody buying more of a hands down by
low-rent high yeah and people will be
and sure you bought that house for
82,000 pounds 82 82 how much is it worth
now I think about between 130 and 140
which is good in three years in this
market I mean incredibly good yeah it
did spend money doing it up yeah I've
completely referred to it spent for this
rap yeah about 20 on it discovered that
saving on that as well which was
interested in part of it but if you
bought afraid tuned you spent 20 on it
that's 102 in yeah and it's gone up to
about how much you say sir 130 140 I'd
like to think 140 right so it's gone up
a lot yeah in four years
yeah so I think I was right in my advice
at the time it was yeah I see any reason
I bought you here yesterday I was right
no and and it's got land at the side of
it so there's development potential
there where they'll build something out
the back or something another house on
the side of it so as a plot it's good
plot as well so there's no one saw the
development Patino good thing as well is
and I know I was a small a small [ __ ]
in the chain to what in your property
journey because you came on the crash
course we did you come out and did we
spend a day together and I show you
around all the Hamptons don't know no I
never did I didn't join the Academy no
no I originally contacted you off the
back of a pin meeting yeah and Kent and
asked you for a bit of a vice and you
know I wanted to buy in Birmingham yeah
following our discussions we had that
night I end up buying you sauced the
house for me which saved me a load of
time to be fair yeah did I sell that
house well you did yeah hard to sell you
know no pressure said it was it was
something come over the email said yep
okay I'm interested cool I had a few
days of details paid the fee house how
much do you remember how much you paid
me mm I think yeah come on say mm mm I
think you meant you to pay my why yeah
you're gonna pay my brother brother yeah
yeah we'll get that now the reason that
as well I want you on this show is
because that house technically did make
you financially for it am i right
it did yeah
you've upped your lifestyle yeah fancy
Range Rover and different yes but that
made you financially free talk to me
about the advantage to that HMO to the
previous buy-to-let so you don't
previously I cashflow I find it more
exciting it was a development I like
doing developments it was it introduced
me to outside of Kent if you like as
development potential and I've learned a
lot from it and I've learnt now about
rent to rents from it I've no let it to
affirm that doing service accommodation
so yeah it's it's and I'm getting into
that world as well so yeah it's been a
it's been a good you would have got to
me quick even you just join the Academy
bro yeah I would have been financially
free no no but I know I I think I think
I didn't I felt that I didn't need to go
into the Academy at the time I'd I'd I
knew he didn't know I think there was
some courses and follow-on courses but I
think there was the deal finding
extravaganza that was it so the Academy
it was his interesting thing you came to
them very very first free property
investors crash course yeah because you
came January 2017 and that was a month
after I just got back from Thailand I
was in Thailand December and in Thailand
I decided you know what the crash course
it's two new 50-pound crash course I'm
gonna do it for two days
not one day and I'm gonna give it away
for free just because I want as many
people to benefit from it as possible
and that was there was 126 people there
previously there being like 50 to 60
there's double the amount of people you
have to admit it was an amazing two days
yeah it was and since then the crash
course has gone on to be the biggest
property training course in the whole of
the UK and you were the very first free
one and yeah 100% is well worth doing
you'll get those for me I took my
brother actually on the same day on the
same day and he's not into property he's
likely probably never will unless it's
an accidental landlord okay but I took
him for the network inside of it I said
you'll get a lot from it from meeting
people being in a room and to be honest
the crash course wasn't what I expected
it was there was points we got stand up
and do things that I wouldn't I
personally wouldn't
even though I was a trained Network if
you like but so I took them skills with
me put you outside your comfort zone
yeah you were talking about life skills
as well yeah listen about that so I
think it's not about you won't you might
not come away from it and be a
successful property entrepreneur or and
all having ten houses but if you can
take a few little skills that you learn
from that crash course whether it's
Network in talking to people coming out
of your comfort zone learning new slowly
new new stuff that a lot of people they
do jobs from nine to five for ten twenty
years and don't learn any new skills all
day long so that gives them the
opportunity to learn other other things
new things so you've got to get get from
what you can and you might that that
skill you learn the network in may bring
you on something else in business or
something else in life and no one not
every single person is created to be a
property millionaire 100% not but you
got to take the skills apply it yeah and
if that means you're going to become
really successful in property or
financially free then also like you've
done yeah but if not then fine
children let's hope to more than what
have been the figures so you bought it
for 82 now worth 130 140 how much has it
been renting out for over the last four
years so there was there was a bit of a
boom in HMOs in the area so there was a
few voids in the rent but generally it
was pretty good to be fair so I used to
get anything between 1350 downwards per
month for rent as is the four rooms yeah
so it was a typical three bedrooms
upstairs to reception rooms turn the
front reception room into a bedroom and
bar from out the back and since then
I've now I'm now renting it to accompany
those renter ents and they do a service
accommodation and I get 850 a month and
that and do they pay the bills they pay
the bills and make the best bit is they
maintain it so basically renting out for
1350 and I don't buy the bills and
maintaining it isn't much different no
from getting 850 we've no voids we've no
voice and you know what's gonna come in
yep on a three-year tenancy great that's
awesome and and and and what the
mortgage payments on that zero you don't
have a mortgage on it no oh you bought
it cash
yeah but I'm really regaining it at the
moment you're about to refinance it yeah
so you're gonna be so right now you're
making 850 so that's a pretty good yield
mmm you happy with the house I am I
haven't been there for about a year and
a half now how many times do you ever
visit the house twice I'm think it's
three times if you count the first time
I went to look at it before I bought it
yeah so you've only been twice after
buying it yeah which brings me on to the
next part which was you paid my wife I
did and she saw you for the first time
today yeah everything was they weren't
sure and remote before that yet so
Amanda furnished it for me I can't even
put a page now for four and a half five
thousand pounds yeah everything you're
probably paid I think she was charging
four and a half thousand pounds which
meant that it would be furnished top to
bottom including TV beds furniture
cutlery rose pans yeah and the laboring
cost of time the flat backing and doing
it yeah four and half grand and at the
time I looked into IKEA furniture yeah
and then by the time you things don't
turn up in you've got in labor bouts to
complete it it worked out a thousand or
2,000 pounds more without all the soft
stuff I'll tell you how much she made on
that she would make profit from the
company about 850 pounds which yeah
that's and from Amanda's point of view
because she had a furnishing company
yeah 850 pounds when you know what to do
and you've got everything on everyone on
speed dial
you've got the van yeah you've got the
flat backers it's not a lot of work she
was making a reason Ramona she was doing
them all the time yeah so I was telling
people deals charging people like you 2
grand
bang bang bang I've done that hundreds
of times I did hundreds in Wolverhampton
I'm pretty confident the reason
Wolverhampton changed into article 4
yeah that yeah I see that is a benefit
because now these hecho Mo's will start
to turn back into they are and then that
the the demand for HMOs or room yeah
already is in mountain so I'm pretty
sure that the council did that
single-handedly because of me
honestly actually selling dozens and
dozens and dozens so I'm making two
thousand pound of pot from people like
you bang bang bang then my wife Amanda
is making 850 bang bang Bang's
why do the furnishing which
everyone's going for 70% of our clients
that I'd sell a deal to used a manner to
furnish and dress the house yeah then
we've got a letting agency quick move
yeah
which belongs to Russell because I like
to keep things out of my name sometimes
right so Russell's got quick move
management company those companies don't
run anymore
we close down quick move when we moved
to London we closed down the furniture
company when we started having kids and
stuff because I didn't want to be doing
that and we didn't want to church for me
it didn't make sense trying to scale up
business and I just thought you know
what I haven't really got the time or
the inclination I'd rather just focus on
my own investment business and my
training company and stuff rather than
trying to do everything all at once yeah
but you know it was a good business you
can be a busy fall you can be a busy
fall what was it like because now I
teach people how to package and sauce
deals interesting that now you're almost
a bit of a deal sourcing because you
work with people on the land side which
we'll get to but did you learn anything
from dealing with me doing business like
my sales or anything or was itwas then
the thing to say about that no I did I
did I think I think the social
networking thing and which I've only
really got into recently for the letting
agent I run but the I think think the
networking side of it and the mentorian
are there was a point where I probably
thought that I could be a property
mentor and whooping and I still do but
now you tell me you don't envy me I I
don't on the scale no and I think I
could mentor property developers yeah or
property but you're better esters yeah
being with them yes which is what you
now you're beginning to bring in your
skills together then you are mentoring
people in a way you're using your
development skills they're putting in
the money but yeah I mean I think how I
got you to buy that deal from me was
obviously for a start as a good deal
okay but I came to that pin meeting was
on the speaker yes he did use to you
have two or three speakers than you and
yeah yeah I think you have two speakers
I think you did the first spot okay yeah
so I spoke did I pitch at the end of my
talk I probably didn't
come on you're allowed No and it all you
all you spoke about was HMOs yeah for
how you want the concept concepts of
HMOs in the Midlands area yeah by high
rent though and the way wrapped by
didn't Aguilar knows there yeah and I
think I read the book yes because what I
used to do at the end of pin talks was I
used to say I used to give loads of as a
value and I would say right if you're
interested drop me a text message here's
my number that's it and that's exactly
what I did and then ninety percent the
people would text me and then I'd follow
up and say hey thanks from you text
here's your the information or ever you
requested also if you're interested in
deals let me know yeah and especially
when you're buying in a different part
of the country or far away and I spent
probably before we engaged over this
property but I spent hours days probably
weeks looking for properties yeah and
what I found is obviously you find the
right property but then by the time you
book a viewing at the weekend or in two
weeks time or they can't do a review and
they're gonna do this time you can't you
can't drive to an area and do ten
viewings a day yeah it's hard work yeah
and you know it's like and also you take
you're on your way up there elsewhere
the property sold yes
so for me that two thousand pounds was
the best mm I've ever spent and I would
have done that in diesel yeah and hotels
and whatever I needed to source that
property yeah I'll see it got moving
quickly yeah makes sense and I want to
encourage anyone watching this and and
and really show them and demonstrate
that being a deal sorcerer show them the
skills and the possibilities and how to
do it right pass on good properties and
how to sell and how to market but then
also the other end which is it's win-win
it is you were happy I was happy at the
time I was doing so many of those deals
that's how I became a millionaire from
from this is how I became a millionaire
yeah all I was financially free 21 years
old 25 I became a millionaire by selling
so many deals yeah because you've only
got a cell what like a few hundred deals
to make a million pounds
and that's assuming that you're only
charged in two to nine thousand pounds
so some of my deals are selling for five
six thousand pounds
it's not that many deals no and you find
your own deals on the way and you find
your own videos on the way and you're
gonna use that money that you're making
to put into your own deals that's right
so you're doing land deal sourcing and
stuff now tell me a little about that so
yeah any developments so coming from a
construction background yeah as well so
I can look at a site I understand I
stand
what's what makes a good site what
doesn't make a good site an idea of what
you can put on the piece of land so yeah
that it was a natural progression really
so who's your ideal client that you
think should talk to you someone someone
who is probably already into property
yeah into developing knots not a green
home feel like not like a newbie no but
if someone's got money then and they
want to invest in in a development I
suggest that you do it with someone
someone that knows what they do yeah
yeah for sure if you've got money but
you've not got the time or the
experience to put that into a big
project you don't want to buy lots of
little houses you want to do some big
development deals it makes sense to
potentially get the education for sure
but also to find someone that has got
the experience and to let them do it for
you as long as you make sure that you
get it drawn up properly of solicitors
you D risk it you're working with people
that you can trust that I've got
experience themself like yourself then
it make sense yeah and you don't want
you don't want to buy it by a by a deal
or someone go out and find a builder
your architects all the different
professionals you need and they go out
and do it yourself and try and manage a
builder yeah if you're not into B there
are no new projects and let someone take
50 percent that's right
then do one project and be so wrapped up
in it and lose 10 20 % just yes but I'll
make it their own disease called boy
errors yeah and I've made schoolboy
errors I still do make schoolboy errors
does because we're all learning roll and
journey every time I do a new project
now when I do projects not only do I
want to make six figures on the project
minimum hopefully seven but six figures
but also I want to learn things yeah I
want to do some have not done before
every slight refresh yeah every so it's
different isn't it yeah and every site
needs he's a different building a
different type of your dinner yeah
exactly no idea
yeah and it's maximizing that that piece
of land yeah or the existing building
you're doing a convert I mean I'll leave
a link or in the description with your
website so if anyone's watching this one
thing in touch talk to you about what
you do or talk to you about any
opportunities that you've got they'll be
able to do that from your website which
looks fantastic it's quite a new website
looks great this year I need a new
property management as well yes yeah so
unless an agent so I've got family
family working on that as well
so yeah we've we've from learning
probably learning learning learning by
mistake maybe yeah but managing their
own properties so I was too tight to
pilot an agent yeah except for HMOs and
stuff that's far away it doesn't pay to
I manage but locally in the properties I
own I self manage and I like to meet the
tenants and and quiz them really and
yeah touch words I've never had any
major issues we have tenants that I've
taken on but that's probably from that
from learn learning from meeting
different people and network in the best
basa you can tell you tell someone's
genuine I suppose but yeah it's when
when wasn't don't we met as well my deal
sourcing company I think I had maybe one
or two members of staff and I tan you
lose this maybe oh yeah I think Elliott
might be maybe and I don't know if they
did a lot of the communications or if
you dealt with me a bit as mainly Tania
and you and yourself yes I was more
involved in the initial sale and then
get I need a lot of the hand-holding the
progression
she needed loads of support you've
you've bought lots of houses before
yourself
it was using your power team at the time
so yeah there's a new word for me this
this power team and it's right you need
the people around you get from your
mortgage brokers to your solicitors yeah
and and it helps if they know the area
as well yes and I used to talk to the
estate agent and I did carried on
talking to that estate agent after that
deal you know and yeah made up a bit of
relationship there as well so how was
Amanda's service she wants to know easy
was she good yeah so it was I think we
had I think it was a two-week leading or
a week leading or something yeah so she
went round
when in measured up on her own I paid I
paid transferred the money and then two
weeks later it was all furnished nice no
trouble at all they're all drink and the
letting agent side of things did they do
it while that until they know a mugs and
already yeah they did okay yeah so I had
them on board before the house was in
the renovation was even finished great
and then and as far as the service with
the sourcing side of things was that
okay
easy yep grazie we like to take your
money that's it took money but didn't
run away we're always there to talk talk
through with estate agent yeah chose
there as well the solicitors everything
it was easy so let that be a testimony
if anyone's watching this if you're
gonna be a deal sorcerer you want to be
like me hundreds of deals like I've done
you've got a number one work with good
people like they number to deliver yeah
good properties and number three is a
good customer service 100% I think
that's that's the moment follow up
follow up I always spoke to Tonya after
afterwards and yeah and that's and it's
just that personal touch mmm that's
important that's great well Leigh it's
great to see you doing wow it's great to
see you continue to smash it in property
and hopefully one day I'll manage to get
you to persuade you to join the Academy
as a mentee or maybe as a mentor on
remember yeah hope you enjoyed that guys
listen you want to get some success we
got to do subscribe to my channel man
you don't have to do anything else maybe
you do maybe you do maybe you should do
watch some more videos pop them up right
here boom maybe you should check the
link in the description come to the
property investors crash course maybe
you should subscribe or hear do
something hope you see you at my house
one day sit down and have a chat with
you about how you succeeded as it was
all my training thanks for watching
subscribe